Hello, everyone. Welcome to another special Friday episode of office ladies. This week, we are sharing our interview with Chelsea Fry from the paper. The paper is coming out on September 4th on Peacock, and we found out they are planning to release the first four episodes. That's right. We got our links to view them before they air. Yes, they sent us the first four episodes. I am so excited. This is one of the benefits of being part of the office universe. We get to see these shows early, and lady, I am here for it. I know. We get to see them, but we do have to wait to do our breakdown until after the show has premiered, because no spoilers. Yeah, so until then, we have to keep everything to ourselves. Oh, by the way, Ang, did you know that there is a rumor that we have cameos on the
大家好。欢迎收听《办公室女士》周五特别节目。本周，我们将分享我们对《The Paper》一员切尔西·弗赖（Chelsea Fry）的采访。《The Paper》将于9月4日在Peacock上线，我们得知他们计划首播前四集。没错。我们在它们播出前就拿到了观看链接。是的，他们把前四集发给我们了。我太激动了。这是成为办公室宇宙成员的好处之一。我们可以提前看到这些剧集，天哪，我太支持了。我知道。我们可以看，但我们必须等到该剧首播后才能进行深度解析，因为不能剧透。是的，所以在那之前，我们必须把一切都保密。哦，对了，安，你知道有个传闻说我们在
paper? Seriously? Yes, yes. Like what kind of rumor? Okay, well, some website, quoted you talking about how we went to the set. And for some reason, that got turned into us having cameos on the show. But you were just talking about how we got to visit. Okay, I didn't muck it up, right? I said visited. No, no, no, no. Okay. You did not, lady. This is one of those examples of how things get twisted, the game of telephone. We should say, I guess, set the record straight, Angela and I do not appear in the paper. Nope. There is a familiar face on the paper. That news is out. Oscar Nunez is reprising his role of Oscar Martinez. That's right. But Jen and I are not on the paper. Correct. Are in the paper. We're not on it or in
《The Paper》里客串了吗？真的吗？对，对。什么样传闻？好吧，某个网站引用了你的话，说我们去了片场。不知怎么的，这就变成了我们在剧中客串。但你当时只是在说我们去参观了。好吧，我没搞砸吧？我说的是参观。不，不，不，不。好吧。你没有，女士。这就是事情被曲解的例子，像传话游戏一样。我想我们应该澄清一下，我和安杰拉并没有出现在《The Paper》中。没有。不过《The Paper》里确实有一张熟悉的面孔。这个消息已经公开了。奥斯卡·努涅斯（Oscar Nunez）将回归饰演奥斯卡·马丁内斯（Oscar Martinez）。没错。但简和我不在《The Paper》里。没错。不在里面或参演。
it. We are not. We just visited it. That's it. Well, I'm glad we cleared that up. And now we really hope that you enjoy this interview with Chelsea Fry. You might know her from the series The Cleaning Lady or Animal Control. She is an absolute sweetheart. Chelsea shares about how she got her job on the paper and the secret code name everyone had to use to keep the show under wraps on the universal lot. Mm-hmm. We hope you enjoy. All right, will you please tell us your name and tell us your character name? I'm Chelsea Frye and my character name is Mayor Preeti. And tell us a little about your character. Mayor is, well, she's an Army event. Um, she's, um, she's, born and raised in Ohio um she's very practical i think she got really used to um her dreams kind of
我们不在。我们只是去参观了。就是这样。很高兴我们澄清了这一点。现在我们真的希望你们会喜欢这次对切尔西·弗赖的采访。你可能从电视剧《清洁工》或《动物控制》中认识她。她是个绝对的甜心。切尔西分享了她是如何得到《The Paper》的工作的，以及为了在环球影城片场对该剧保密，每个人都必须使用的神秘代号。嗯。希望你们喜欢。好的，能请你告诉我们你的名字和你的角色名吗？我是切尔西·弗赖，我的角色是市长普里蒂（Mayor Preeti）。跟我们多聊聊你的角色吧。市长嘛，嗯，她是一个陆军退伍军人。嗯，她，嗯，是在俄亥俄州土生土长的，嗯，她非常务实，我觉得她真的很习惯，嗯，她的梦想有点
like not working out i think she you know worked here for a while and um saw how it was run and didn't really think anything would change and um then when ned shows up i think kind of this fire is reignited in her of hope and excitement and doing something maybe she cares about with their life. I think she used to just go to work as, you know, the job. And now it's kind of something more exciting, which is nice. So catching her at an interesting moment in her life. So you mentioned your character was born and raised in Ohio. But what about you? I'm from Boston. I grew up in Andover, Massachusetts, small town like right outside of Boston. And then I moved to New York for college. So I was there like when I was 18. I lived there for six years. And then I moved
像没能实现，我觉得她，你知道，在这里工作了一段时间，嗯，看到它是如何运作的，觉得什么都不会改变，嗯，然后当内德（Ned）出现时，我觉得她心中的希望和兴奋之火被重新点燃了，去做一些她可能真正关心的事情。我觉得她以前去上班，你知道，就只是一份工作。而现在这有点像更令人兴奋的事情，这很好。所以这是在她人生的一个有趣时刻捕捉到了她。所以你提到你的角色是在俄亥俄州土生土长的。那你呢？我来自波士顿。我在马萨诸塞州安多弗长大的，那是波士顿郊外的一个小镇。然后我为了上大学搬到了纽约。所以我18岁左右就在那里了。我在那里住了六年。然后我搬
out here. But now I got my entire family to move out here. So we're all California people now. Yeah. All right. So we always ask everyone, how did you get your job on the office? So how did you get your job on the paper? Can you tell us about your audition process? Oh my God. It's crazy. I'm sure is, you know, the stories always are, but I was in New York shooting something and I had a really rough year during the strike. I was the lead of a show for two years that was just a strike casualty and they were just like, we're throwing it in the trash. And I was like, I just really did never, never saw. It was kind of like my dream job that I was just like, well, that's, you know, now in the trash and nobody's ever going to see it.
到了这里。不过现在我把全家人都搬到这里来了。所以我们现在全都是加州人了。好。所以我们总是问每个人，你是怎么得到《办公室》的工作的？那你又是怎么得到《The Paper》的工作的呢？能跟我们讲讲你的试镜过程吗？天哪。太疯狂了。我敢肯定，正如大家所知，故事总是如此，但我当时正在纽约拍一部戏，在罢工期间我度过了非常艰难的一年。我曾连续两年担任一部剧的主演，结果该剧成了罢工的牺牲品，他们直接说，我们把它扔进垃圾桶吧。当时我就想，我真的从来、从来没料到。这有点像我的梦想工作，而我当时就觉得，好吧，这，你知道，现在进垃圾桶了，而且永远不会有人看到了。
And I was in a dark, dark hole as I'm, you know, we all kind of worked during that time. But anyway, I was luckily shooting a really sweet rom-com in New York playing just a fun little side character. And I did, you know, the audition. You, like, didn't know anything about the part. And so it was, you know, kind of just like dummy sides. So I was like, whatever. I'm just going to have fun with it. Like, I'm never going to hear about this again.
我当时处在一个黑暗、黑暗的深渊里，正如我所知，我们所有人那段时间都在努力工作。不过无论如何，幸运的是，我在纽约拍一部非常温馨浪漫的喜剧，扮演一个有趣的小配角。然后我做了，你知道，试镜。你，就像对这个角色一无所知。所以它，你知道，基本上就是假台词。所以我想，随便吧。我只是要从中找点乐子。反正，我再也不会听到这个消息了。
You know, it was kind of like the rumor going around that it was like the office reboot. But I have one thing to say. So we, so your audition sides were nothing that gave anything away about what you were doing. Is that correct? Yes. Yes. It literally said like untitled Greg Daniels and then the sides. I didn't even know what they were about.
你知道，当时到处流传着它是《办公室》重启版的传闻。但我有一句话要说。所以我们，所以你的试镜台词没有任何泄露你所做内容的信息。对吗？是的。是的。上面真的写着类似“未命名的格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）”，然后就是台词。我甚至不知道它们是关于什么的。
Not about a newspaper. I didn't know what the character was. Literally nothing. And so, yeah. I just kind of put it on tape and totally improvised it with my friend Blake. And he was so sweet and did it with me a bunch. And I was like, great. Like, again, I'm never going to hear.
不是关于报纸的。我不知道这个角色是什么。简直一无所知。所以，是的。我只是把它录了下来，和我的朋友布莱克（Blake）一起即兴发挥了。他太好了，陪我排练了好几次。然后我说，太好了。就像我说的，我再也不会听到了。
Like, I'm just never going to actually be up for this job. And so then I got a call that they wanted to see me, but I was in New York. And I, they were like, you can go to 30 Rock, which was like, okay. Like, I interned there when I was in. I interned there. You did? Yes, I interned on Conan O'Brien. I interned at late night with Seth Myers and then S&L.
就像我永远不会真的得到这份工作一样。然后我接到一个电话，说他们想见我，但我当时在纽约。然后他们说，你可以去洛克菲勒中心30号，当时我就想，好吧。就像，我在那儿实习过。我在那儿实习过。你实习过？对，我在柯南·奥布莱恩（Conan O'Brien）那儿实习过。我在《赛斯·迈尔斯深夜秀》实习过，然后是《周六夜现场》。我在周末的时候在《周六夜现场》工作。你在开玩笑吧？所以这太超现实了。就像我走回去，你知道，遇到了在那里的迈克尔·科曼（Michael Komen）。我们进去了。当时的感觉是，我太、太感激我当时认为自己绝不可能得到这份工作了，因为我觉得自己玩得很开心。因为我当时想，我绝对，再来一次，就像，甚至直到今天，我都觉得，我绝不可能、绝不可能得到这份工作。就像，我做着那份我
I worked on the weekends on S&L. Are you kidding me? So it's like so surreal. Like I like walked back in and, you know, met Michael Komen, who was there. And we went in. And it was like, I'm so, I'm so grateful that I thought I would never get the job because I think I just had so much fun. Because I was like, I just, I'm never, again, like, it just like, even to the this day, I'm like, I'm never, I'm never going to get this job. Like, I'm doing the job that I'm
永远不可能真正得到的工作。然后我进去了，他们留了我大约两个小时，我们只是，他们问了关于我的事，问我来自哪里，然后他们把这些融入到了角色中。那是我一生中最超现实的日子之一。除了迈克尔之外，其他所有人都在Zoom上，但他一直在看着我，给我竖起大拇指。然后，是的，那天晚些时候我接到电话，说我去
never actually going to get. And I went in and they kept me for like two hours and we just, they asked about me and about where I'm from and we're kind of like incorporating that into the character. And it was just one of the most surreal days of my life. Like, everybody else was on Zoom besides Michael, but he was kind of looking at me, like giving me like a little thumbs up. And, yeah, then I got a call later that day that I was. in a chemistry read. And this is where it's funny. I thought the show was set in Boston,
参加化学反应试镜了。有趣的地方就在这里。我以为这部剧背景在波士顿，
kind of like based on just like how we were talking. And so I started like making her really Boston-y when I came back in for the chemistry. And they were like, what are you doing? I was like, I thought she was supposed to have an accent. I was just kind of going crazy. And I then wrote Greg a letter saying that like I just wanted the part so bad. And because it was dummy sides, I thought her name was Paula.
有点像根据我们谈话的方式。所以我去参加化学反应复试时，开始让她听起来非常像波士顿人。然后他们说，你在干什么？我说，我以为她应该有口音。我当时有点疯了。然后我给格雷格（Greg）写了一封信，说我太想要这个角色了。因为那是假台词，我以为她的名字叫宝拉（Paula）。
I thought she was from Boston. I wrote this like heartfelt letter of why like nobody else can play Paula from Boston and it was like I just really put it all out there because I was like when else am I getting get the chance to write something to Greg Daniels
我以为她是波士顿人。我写了一封感人的信，解释为什么没有人能扮演来自波士顿的宝拉，我当时真的是把所有想法都倾倒出来了，因为我想，我什么时候还能有机会给格雷格·丹尼尔斯写信呢？
that he might actually read like whatever and then I got the part and her name is not Paula she's not from Boston I was like so embarrassed I was like oh my God and I like made it seem like there's nobody else who can do this like what I was terrible
他可能真的会读，管他呢，然后我得到了这个角色，而她的名字不叫宝拉，她也不是波士顿人。当时我尴尬极了，我想，天哪，我还搞得好像没有人能演这个角色一样，像个什么样，我太糟糕了。
but yeah that was the and then I got the call and it was the craziest thing ever. I still can't believe it. I'm like, yeah. This is an ad by BetterHelp. You know, it feels like nowadays there's advice for just about everything. It's like, do you write in your journal, do you do, I don't know, cleanses or the cold plunge or, you know, what helps you get through the day? What helps you get through stressful moments?
不过，是的，这就是，然后我接到了电话，这是最疯狂的事情。我至今仍不敢相信。我当时想，是的。这是一则来自BetterHelp的广告。你知道，感觉现在几乎每件事都有建议。就像，你写日记吗，你做，我不知道，排毒或者冷水浴，或者，你知道，什么能帮度过这一天？什么能帮你度过压力时刻？
Mm-hmm. For me, it's talking it out. Mm-hmm. Well, there can be a lot of information overload about mental health and wellness, and it can be a struggle to know what's true and what actions to take these days. So you might think about using a trusted resource and talking to live therapists through better help. It has an app store rating of 4.9 out of 5 based on over 1.7 million client reviews.
嗯。对我来说，是把事情说出来。嗯。嗯，关于心理健康和健康的信息可能会过载，如今要想知道什么是真的、该采取什么行动可能会是一种挣扎。所以你可以考虑使用一个值得信赖的资源，通过BetterHelp与真人治疗师交谈。它在应用商店里获得了4.9星的高分（满分5分），这是基于170万客户评价得出的。
As the largest online therapy provider in the world, BetterHelp can provide access to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Talk it out with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10% off their first month at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. That's BetterHelp-H-E-L-P.com slash office ladies. Hurry! What is the rush? They're only open until September. What? Leguans.
作为全球最大的在线治疗提供商，BetterHelp可以让你接触到拥有各种不同专业领域的心理健康专家。通过BetterHelp把心事说出来。我们的听众在BetterHelp.com/officeladies网站首次订阅即可享受九折优惠。网址是BetterHelp-H-E-L-P.com/officeladies。快点！急什么？它们只营业到九月。什么？鬣蜥。
Is that why we're in Coburg Beach? Here, here. Order me the mother-clockers. A chicken. sandwich. Not just a chicken sandwich, Arthur. Chicken. Marinated for 24 hours and tossed in their blend of herbs and spices before they become gold and crispy, slapped between two Guyanese sweet buns that are toasted to buttery perfection. It's the best chicken sandwich in the world. All right. Yeah, that does sound pretty good. You're damn right.
这就是为什么我们在科堡海滩？给，给。给我点那个他妈的。鸡肉三明治。不仅仅是鸡肉三明治，亚瑟。鸡肉。腌制24 hours，并在香草和香料混合物中裹匀，然后炸得金黄酥脆，夹在两个圭亚那甜面包之间，烤得黄油香浓。这是世界上最好吃的鸡肉三明治。好吧。是的，听起来确实挺不错。你说得对极了。
So on the show, it's the same documentary crew that followed the folks at Dunder Mifflin, and now they're following you all here at the paper, what has it been like for you to like acknowledge the camera or look right at the camera? Was that a weird adjustment? Yeah, it is. I think it's also, I mean, I cannot tell you how many times I've rewatched the office. It's like the thing that I, you know, it's as everyone in the world, it was like my comfort show, my everything show, the show that when I'm working and away from home, it like reminds me of home and makes me, feel better. So I know everything. He'd be like
所以在剧中，是那个曾经跟随邓德米夫林员工的纪录片摄制组，现在他们跟随你们大家来到《The Paper》，对你来说，承认镜头或者直视镜头是什么感觉？这是一个奇怪的适应过程吗？是的，确实是。我想这也是，我是说，我无法告诉你我重温了多少次《办公室》。这就像是我，你知道的，正如世上所有人一样，它是我的治愈剧，我的一切，每当我工作并远离家时，它就会让我想起家，让我感觉更好。所以我什么都知道。他会说
you know the episode and I would like pretend. I'd be like right. Yeah, no, the dinner party episode. I think I've seen that one. I'm like, I've seen it a hundred times. So anyway, I was so nervous about making it seem like I was kind of putting on something, like trying to do something that you guys had done. So the thing that I found was like trying to find
你知道那一集，我会假装。我会说对。对，没错，晚宴那一集。我想我看过那一集。我说过，我看过一百遍了。总之，我当时非常紧张，生怕自己看起来像是在刻意伪装，像是在模仿你们做过的事。所以我发现的方法就是试着寻找
like my exact relationship to it and like whatever what I want from what I want whenever I'm looking at the camera and you know what also I want the camera not to know um but it's definitely taken a minute I feel like I actually don't know but I feel like somebody was like she needs to stop looking at the camera as much because during a couple episodes they're like you don't need to look at the camera for that one I was like okay I'm doing doing it too much um but yeah it's been a fun it's so fun I've never done a show like that where you get to interact with it I'm like scared for like the next thing if I ever, you know, work again.
我与它的确切关系，以及无论我在看镜头时想要什么，以及我知道我希望镜头不知道什么。但确实花了一点时间。我觉得，其实我不知道，但我觉得有人曾说过她需要减少看镜头的次数，因为在拍摄好几集期间他们说，那一集你不需要看镜头。我说，好吧，我做得太多了。不过，是的，这很有趣，太有趣了。我从未拍过这样能与镜头互动的剧。我很担心接下来如果我再工作的话。
And the next thing I do, I'm going to, like, be, like, looking at the camera. They're going to be, like, stop. It happens. Yeah. I mean, I, yeah, I think the job I had after the office was a Netflix show. And I looked right down the barrel of the camera one time. And they were like, hey, Angela, can you not look down the camera? Stop.
接下来的工作，我会，像，盯着镜头看。他们会说，停下。这种情况会发生。对。我是说，我，是的，我觉得我拍完《办公室》之后的下一部工作是一部网飞剧。我有一次直接盯着镜头看了。然后他们说，嘿，安杰拉，你能别看镜头吗？停下。
Okay, that makes you feel better. Wow. I want to ask you guys questions. You're going to be. How is it being back here? How do you guys feel? well it's really exciting to see some of our crew members that cross over um that's been actually really emotional um i mean i wish all the time that i could wake up and just like go back to one
好吧，这让我感觉好多了。哇。我想问你们几个问题。你们要。回到这里感觉怎么样？你们有什么感受？嗯，看到一些我们的老剧组工作人员重聚，真的让人很兴奋。那其实真的让人很感慨。我是说，我无时无刻不在希望自己能醒来，然后回到过去的那一天，再次回到片场，和包括我们剧组在内的所有人在一起，拍摄一集。所以，看到大家，我真的觉得有点多愁善感。我们走过来时，见到的第一个人是来自，你知道的，大牌餐饮公司的塞尔吉奥（Sergio）。他，我是说，塞尔吉奥喂饱了我们九年。他陪我们度过了怀孕的种种嘴馋，还有，呃，直到现在我们依然像一家人的演员和剧组。我认为我们是一个大家庭，我们依然支持彼此，为彼此捧场。所以我希望你也能有这样的体验，因为这真的非常特别。是的。那是最好的事情之一，听到有多少人回来参与制作。他们说，这真的是，我是说，他们一直在谈论。
day in the past and be on the set again and just with all the people including our crew and um make an episode so it's been a little bit i feel sentimental seeing people well we walked up the first person we saw was Sergio from, you know, big time catering. He, I mean, Sergio fed us for nine years. He got us both through like pregnancy cravings and, uh, the cast and the crew that we're still like a family. I think of us as a family and we still support each other and show up for each other. So I hope that for you because it's really special. Yeah. It's, that has been one of the nicest things is hearing how many people came back from doing it. And they were like, it was, I mean, they talk about it all the time.
他们说，因为这也是真的，就像，现在，触木逢生，你拍了一部能延续好几季以上的剧，但这太罕见了。听到他们说，看着他们的孩子长大，看着你们，你们所有人都经历婚姻，这太疯狂了。这太特别了，听到关于，是的，每个，我是说，我只是，像，想到剧组里的每一个人，但它，真的感觉你们创造的东西真正传承了下来，并创造了如此特别的东西，你能感受到。我甚至能身处其中并听到这些故事，就已经觉得自己太幸运了。好吧我知道你提到过你的
They're like, because it's also true, like, now, you know, knock on wood, you get a show that goes on longer than a couple seasons, but it's so rare. And to hear about, like, you know, them seeing their children grow up and seeing you, like, all of you just go through marriages and it's just, it's crazy. It's, it's so special and it's so fun to hear about with, yeah, every, I mean, I'm just, like, thinking of every single person on the crew, but it's, uh, it really feels like what you guys created has just truly carried on and made something so special and you can feel it. I feel so lucky to even just like be around it and hear the stories. Well, I know that you mentioned that your
家人现在都和你在这里。而且我们也知道每个人都发誓要保密。是的。在整个拍摄期间。是的。当你的家人发现你接到这份工作时，那是怎样一种体验？在假期里，当他们想知道内幕而你又不能告诉他们时，又是什么体验？现在情况是怎样的？你有没有一个像苍蝇一样缠着每个人的阿姨，而你又处在信息封锁状态？好吧，首先，你说出这些可能会被解雇。真的，就像我的经纪人们打电话告诉我时，他们说，绝对不要告诉任何人。我当时都快哭了。
family is all out here with you now. And we also know that everyone has been sworn to secrecy. Yeah. During this whole taping. Yeah. What was it like when your family found out you booked this job? and what has it been like for you at holidays when they want to know stuff and you cannot tell them? What is the situation? Do you have like an aunt who's like pestering everyone and you're on like lockdown information? Well, first, you could probably get fired for saying this. Literally, like my agents called me when they told me they were like, do not tell anybody. I was like cry.
我就想，天哪。我当时还处在这个状态。我当时在吃晚饭，然后你绝对不能说。就像不要告诉你的家人。不要告诉你的男朋友，什么的。当时我就想，当然不。结果我立刻给妈妈打电话，我说，我拿下了。
I was like, oh my God. I was also like on this. I was like at a dinner and you cannot tell it. Like do not tell your family. Don't tell your boyfriend, whatever. I was like, of course not. Literally immediately called my mom. I was like, I got it.
这太糟糕了。然后我告诉我妈，我说，你绝对不能说。而且我的，我爱我妈妈，她是世界上嘴巴最大的人。而且她为我感到骄傲，我很喜欢这一点。但当时的情况是，我说，这个你真的不能说。然后我开始变得真的很紧张，因为我能看出她告诉了家人，当时我就想，如果我因为这个丢了工作。不管怎样，抛开这些不谈，不告诉别人真的很艰难。
which is so bad. And then I told my mom, I was like, you cannot tell. And like my, I love my mother, the biggest mouth in the world. And like, she's so proud of me, which I love. But it's like, I was like, this one you really can't tell. And then I started getting really nervous because I could like tell that she told family member, I was like, if I lose my job because of this. So anyway, besides that, it is hard not telling people.
我是说，我们有一个像假名字一样的代号，Zoom-Sum。 已经成了，我们大家基本上都叫它Zoom-Sum。我觉得我以后会永远叫它Zoom-Sum。不过，是的，保密确实挺好玩的。
I mean, we have this like fake name, Zoom. that has become, we kind of all just call it Zoom, Zoom, Sue. I feel like I'm going to continue to call it Zoom, Zoom for forever. But yeah, it is, it's fun to keep it
阿兰·哈维（Alan Havy）也在剧中，他太棒了，他给了我很好的建议，因为他拍过《广告狂人》的最后几季，他说，在剧集播出之前他谁都不能告诉。他说，我跟你说，在这个时代，我们现在，就像，我们在事情发生的每一秒都会发动态，比如在Instagram上。
a secret. Alan Havy, who's on the show, who's amazing, he's had really good advice because he did the last season of Mad Men, and he was like, he couldn't tell anybody up until it came out. And he's like, I'm telling you, in a day and age, we're now, like, we post
他说，最酷的一点就是没有人知道，然后剧集突然播出，每个人都惊呼，天哪。他说，你大概是第一次有机会做这样的事情。这绝对太酷了。所以当简和我今天到达时，我们的路线指引是去Zoom-Sum。我是说对了吗？
every single thing as it happens, like on Instagram, He's like, there's something so cool about nobody knowing and then the show just dropping and everybody being like, oh my God. And he was saying, he's like, you get that chance for the first time probably to do something like that. That is definitely so cool. So when Jenna and I arrived today, our directions were to zoom-soom. Am I saying it right?
Soom-sum。所以即使在这里的环球片场，当你拍摄时，没有任何地方写着《The Paper》？是的。这挺疯狂的，对吧？我是说，这是一个很大的片场。而你们是Soom-sum。我们是Soom-sum。是的。
Soom-sum. So even here on the universal lot, while you're filming, nowhere does it say the paper? Yeah. That's pretty wild, right? I mean, this is a big lot. and you're Sum-Sum. And we're Sum-Sum. Yeah.
停车场的女士，当时我说，对，我要去Soom-sum。她说，你在2160号停车场。我不知道。就像，她根本不理睬。好吧，你知道它的由来吗？不，Soom-sum的由来是什么？等等，朱利安娜（Giuliana）在这吗？没有。
The lady at the parking structure, I was like, yeah, I'm going to Soom-Sum. She was like, you're in parking 2160. I don't know. Like, she was like not having it. Well, do you know the story of it? No, what is the story of Sum-Sum? Wait, is Giuliana here? No.
朱利安娜是格雷格的助理。所以当他们写剧本时，很显然他们每天都要吃午餐。而且有一家非常棒的，我想是地中海餐厅，叫Soom-sum。我猜朱利安娜，他的助理，总是想吃Soom-sum，她会说，你就会说，好吧，我们午餐想吃什么？
Juliana Gregg's assistant. So while they were writing it, obviously they would get lunch every day. And there's this really amazing, I think Mediterranean restaurant, Soom-Sum. and I guess Juliana, his assistant, always wanted Sum-Sum, and she'd be like you'd be like, okay, what do we want for luncheon?
她会说，Soom-sum？然后这就成了个梗。所以有一天他们就问格雷格，他们说，哦，你希望化名或其他什么叫什么？然后他说，我没想过把它当成名字。他说，就叫Soom-sum吧，随便啦。现在就像是，真的每次
She'd be like, Sum-Sum? And it became a thing. And so one day they just asked Greg, they were like, oh, what do you want the alias or whatever to be? And he was like, I didn't think about it being the name of it. He was like, just call it Sum-Sum, like whatever. And now it's like literally every time
我们到处拉赞助。我们现在都有印着Soom-sum的水壶了。是的，我不知道那家餐厅知道吗，我觉得不知道。他们会知道的。我想总有一天会知道的。哦，太棒了。谢谢你抽空跟我们坐在一起，我们希望，等剧集播出后，我们很乐意邀请你来我们的工作室，你可以跟我们聊更多。
like we're pulling it everywhere. We have like water bottles with Sum-Sum on them now. Yeah, I wonder if there restaurant knows, I don't think so. They will. We'll one day, I think. Oh, well, this was so great. Thank you for sitting down with us, and we hope that, like, once the show comes out, we'd love to have you in our studio and you can talk to us more.
好吧，你可以告诉我们更具体的剧情走向。没错。是的，你可以告诉我们，比如，你角色的整个故事弧光。我们很乐意分享。谢谢你们。非常感谢。这简直像做梦一样。非常感谢。
Well, you can tell us more specific storyline. Exactly. Yeah, you can tell us, like, you know, the whole arc of your character. We'd love to share about it. Thank you guys. So much. This is a dream. Thank you so much.
跟她在一起真的很开心。是的。是的，其实她是我们采访的第一批人之一。她真的让我感到轻松，我很感激这一点。我想她当时很紧张，因为我们是她关于《The Paper》的第一个采访。但我们采访她时也很紧张。是的。你知道，当切尔西谈到对家人保密时，我想起了那是什么感觉。
She's just so fun to be around. Yeah. Yeah, she was one of the first interviews that we did, actually. And she really put me at ease, which I appreciate it. I think she was nervous to talk to us because we were her first interview about the paper. But we were nervous to talk to her. Yes. You know, when Chelsea talked about keeping stuff secret from her family, I remember what that was like.
因为我们在《办公室》里也这样做过。我是说，我们非常有名的在季终集里对史蒂夫（Steve）的回归保密，但我记得吉姆在赌场之夜吻了帕姆之后，我的家人一直在追问我第二季和第三季之间会发生什么。哦，真的吗？是的，他们想知道，我还会和罗伊在一起吗？我和吉姆在一起了吗？我什么都没说。
Because we did that on the office. I mean, we very famously kept Steve's return in the finale a secret, but I remember my family completely hounding me about what was going to happen between season two and season three after Jim kissed Pam on Casino Night. Oh, yeah? Yeah, they wanted to know, like, would I still be with Roy? Did I get with Jim? I didn't say anything.
当然没有。好吧，你知道的，我很喜欢切尔西关于她的试镜以及她一开始如何全身心投入波士顿口音的故事吗？我太喜欢了。那太棒了。好吧，听着，谢谢你们的收听。下周五，我们将迎来极具魅力的萨布里纳·伊姆佩蒂托雷（Sabrina Impacciatore）。哦，萨布里纳。
Of course not. Well, you know, I love Chelsea's story about her audition and how she really, really committed to a Boston accent at first? I love that. That was great. Well, listen, thanks for listening. Next Friday, we are back with the super charming Sabrina impetitore. Oh, Sabrina.
我是说，萨布里纳，我记住了你的每一个字。我真的迫不及待地想让你们听到这一期。好吧，那下周见。谢谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是奥德赛（Odyssey）的一档节目，由简·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）和安杰拉·金斯利（Angela Kinsey）制作。我们的执行制作人是卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins）。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer），我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科（Ainsley Bubbicoe）。奥德赛的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。
I mean, Sabrina, I hung on your every word. I seriously can't wait for you to hear this one. All right. Well, see you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher. and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨（Bill Schultz）混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《Ruppertree》。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《Office Ladies》由Bill Schultz进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是Creed Bratton创作的《Ruppertree》。谢谢。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。